bonjour politologue chercheur aussi
hip-hop merci également d'être avec nous
et Quentin nous a rejoint bonjour
Quentin on va parler de la réforme des
retraites Elisabeth band rencontre les
syndicats mercredi au moment où la page
Martinez se tourne à la CGT alors cela
peut-il fragiliser l'unité syndicale on
va en parler avec vous et puis on sera
avec Bernard vivier spécialiste des
Syndicates est avec nous depuis
Clermont-Ferrand où se tient justement
le congrès de la CGT l'autre débat c'est
Emmanuel Macron tour-t-il la page des
retraites hier il était dans les
Hautes-Alpes pour pour présenter son
plan haut mais il a été rattrapé par sa
réforme des retraites entre militants
contestation inadu c'est expliquer il
garde le cap le chef de l'État on verra
ça dans le club d'abord on regarde
ensemble l'actualité dans nos régions
[Musique]
l'actualité dans nos régions grâce à nos
partenaires de la presse régionale et on
va déjà Clermont-Ferrand on retrouve
Gilles Lalloz bonjour Gilles merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous directeurs des
éditions du Puy-de-Dôme à la rédaction
de la montagne et Clermont-Ferrand
Gilles accueille donc depuis le début de
la semaine de 53e congrès de la CGT et
le mot qu'on puisse dire c'est que
l'ambiance est plutôt tendue
tout à fait ce congrès qui se déroule en
présence d'un millier de délégués venus
de toute la France va laisser à
l'évidence des traces on a vu à
clairement un syndicat divisé un congrès
sous tension un suspense total pour
connaître ce matin le nom du successeur
de Philippe Martinez qui est à la tête
du de la CGT depuis 2015 il y a bien eu
mardi matin lors de la manifestation
contre la réforme des retraites un petit
bol d'air dans les rues de
Clermont-Ferrand car pour sa dernière
manifestation comme leader de la CGT
Philippe Martinez n'a pas cherché la
lumière mais les projecteurs se sont
tout de même braqués sur lui il y a eu
des selfies des poignées de main des
échanges avec d'autres manifestants et
Philippe Martinez lui avait fait
volontairement un pas en retrait pour
pas être à la tête du cortège pendant
toute la manifestation pourtant dès
qu'il est revenu au Congrès la fronde
est revenue de deux plus belles puisque
le il y a eu le rejet de son rapport
d'activité de la direction sortante avec
des critiques sur les orientations de la
CGT sur le manque de démocratie interne
et sur l'approbation par Philippe mart
d'une médiation sur le dossier des
retraites médiation avancées par Laurent
Berger et la CFDT ce qui a fait dire
dans la foulée à Céline vers zélati
c'est un désaveu de tout ce qui a été
mené par la direction sortante une
Céline vers zélatique qui ont le sait et
candidate elle à la succession de
Philippe Martinez tout comme Marie
buisson qui est la candidate soutenue
par Philippe Martinez et d'ailleurs
juste avant le débat sur ce sur ce sujet
de la succession Philippe Martinez nous
avait confié dans les colonnes de la
montagne que un travailleur sur deux est
une femme or la CGT en 128 ans
d'existence n'a toujours pas élu une
femme à sa tête on verra ce matin
puisque c'est ce matin qu'on va
apprendre le nom de la personne qui va
succéder Philippe Martinez à la tête de
la CGT si c'est une femme ou un homme
qui prendra ses succession et si le
syndicat pourra retrouver une certaine
unité avec ce qui semble le seul point
commun entre toutes les lignes c'est à
dire voir la CGT redevenir la première
organisation syndicale du pays et on se
dit qu'il y a bien du travail après ce
qu'on a vu tout au de la semaine entre
eux quand t'as Philippe Martinez lui il
quittera ses fonctions et il a annoncé
que le 3 avril dans quelques jours donc
lui le technicien métallurgie de
formation retourné chez Renault aux
Technocentre de Guyancourt merci
beaucoup merci Gilles d'avoir été avec
nous on regarde la une de la montagne
tout autre sujet et si on pouvait sauver
les abeilles c'est à la Une de votre
journal ce matin merci beaucoup Gilles
Lalloz d'avoir été avec nous pour nous
parler de ce congrès de la CGT Bernard
vivier vous êtes avec nous depuis
Clermont-Ferrand on va en parler
évidemment
l'ambiance tendue à la CGT qu'est-ce que
ça signifie pour voir Noël ce qu'on va
vers une radicalisation de ce syndicat
c'est difficile de le dire bon c'est pas
la première fois quand même qu'il y a
des tensions à la CGT la réalité c'est
que ces tensions apparaissent dans un
moment qui est compliqué parce que c'est
un moment de mobilisation sociale très
fort contre cette réforme des retraites
la question est de savoir si finalement
ces tensions vont avoir un impact ou non
sur la mobilisation et sur j'allais dire
la cohérence de la mobilisation jusqu'à
maintenant c'est le vrai sujet me
semble-t-il au delà de la question
interne de la CGT qui est un autre sujet
mais dans le moment c'est me semble-t-il
la véritable interrogation moi je crois
pas je pense que de toute façon
dans le dans le contexte actuel à court
terme de toute façon
j'allais dire les les opposants à la
réforme ont tout intérêt compte tenu de
la position du gouvernement à rester
unis me semble-t-il tactiquement après
la dynamique des événements est telle
qu'on peut pas prévoir exactement ce qui
va se passer c'est évident Bruno sur
après on va évidemment parler des
conséquences sur le mouvement et sur
l'Inter syndical mais sur ce que ça veut
dire de ce qu'est la CGT aujourd'hui
ce que ça veut dire de la CGT
aujourd'hui d'abord c'est que comme
toutes les organisations à la fois
politique syndicales dans leur ensemble
on voit que elles sont traversées par
bien davantage de au fond de la question
de la démocratie interne qui est une
question qui est devenue aujourd'hui
fondamentale dans toutes les
organisations ni les parties ni les
syndicats de ce point de vue là ne sont
dans les mêmes problématiques ou les
mêmes questions qu'il y a 20 30 40 ans
on voit que cette question ne cesse de
progresser dans l'ensemble des segments
de la vie politique sociale et c'est
vrai que là il y a une balle de match
une certaine manière à ne pas louper
pour les organisations syndicales elles
sont venues au premier plan avec une
très forte visibilité
dans le réforme des retraites et il y a
là quelque chose qui est fondamental
puisqu'on voit bien que l'un des points
faibles de notre système
socio-politique c'est la question de la
démocratie sociale et du lien entre
démocratie sociale et démocratie
politique les syndicats viennent de
retrouver aux yeux des Français des
Français un rôle extrêmement important
on a vu qu'à quel point il était
essentiel qu'il soit les organisateurs
et les canaux de l'expression de la
demande de la demande sociale donc il
faut qu'il soit au rendez-vous de ce
grand moment ça ne nos points faibles en
France nous ne savons tous et donc de ce
point de vue là voir des organisations
syndicales comme la CGT ayant des débats
internes etc c'est plutôt une bonne
chose on va voir ce qu'on pense Bernard
Rivier merci d'être avec nous depuis
Clermont-Ferrand où se tient ce congrès
de la CGT Gilles laloz le disait dans
une ambiance tendue et c'est un congrès
aussi difficile pour Philippe Martinez
qui a été quelque peu désavoué
oui il a été déjà voué il va ce matin
demain il aura d'ailleurs 62 ans ça a
été dit il va retourner au Technocentre
de Guyancourt à Renaud mais la grande
question c'est où va la CGT et c'est un
débat relativement récent
Bernard Thibault a été un grand
secrétaire général de la CGT de 1999 à
2013 et il avait réussi à concilier
progressivement contestation et
négociation il avait aussi lancé l'idée
d'un syndicalisme rassemblé c'est-à-dire
ne pas laisser une CGT seule il n'a pas
réussi sa succession
Philippe Martinez est arrivé en février
2015 et depuis 8 ans la CGT fait du sur
place elle n'a pas débattu en interne de
son évolution de son positionnement et
on ne peut pas accuser uniquement
Philippe Martinez Philippe Martinez
c'est le résultat de ce que sont les
branches professionnelles les
fédérations de la CGT et aussi les
structures territorial donc nous avons
une CGT qui fait du surplace qui
n'avance pas recul en 2017 la CGT est
passée deuxième organisation syndicale
la CFDT de ce fait un a profité elle a
pas beaucoup grandi là c'est le DT mais
elle est devenue la première et nous
sommes aujourd'hui devant une nouvelle
crise de succession qui n'est en fait
que la révélation de ce que vit la CGT
aujourd'hui c'est une sorte d'âge de la
confusion ou devons-nous aller se débat
n'a pas eu lieu au Congrès il n'aura pas
lieu tout de suite et donc on
cristallise évidemment sur les personnes
buisson vers zélité vers zélité buisson
le suspense est immense puisque à cette
heure-ci nous ne savons pas encore
officiellement qui est la future
secrétaire général de la CGT est-ce
que selon le choix ça va changer la
ligne de la CGT on a l'impression mais
vous êtes mieux placé pour nous le dire
que ce qui est reproché à Philippe
Martinez c'est peut-être d'être un petit
peu trop tendre
non Philippe Martinez n'est pas tendre
il l'a montré
les la réforme des retraites a
d'ailleurs permis dans cette période
difficile à l'intérieur de la CGT de
rassembler il n'y a pas eu au cours de
ce congrès beaucoup de débats sur la
réforme des retraites les deux succès
les deux personnes qui peuvent succéder
à Philippe Martinez sont sur la même
ligne la CGT elle-même et dans une ligne
de repli vous savez quand on ne sait pas
vers où on va quand on doute un peu on
durcit le ton c'est ce qu'a fait
Philippe Martinez dans le doute il a
exprimé des positions dures et puis la
sociologie de la CGT et dans cette ligne
là au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle en 2022
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a fait 42% auprès des
sympathisants des personnes qui disent
proches de la CGT Marine Le Pen 22% et
cela veut dire donc des formations
politiques populistes comme on dit qui
font à l'intérieur de la CGT et bien 64%
presque les deux tiers de la CGT ont
porté les voix leur voix vers ces deux
candidats
Bernard viviers après je redonne la
parole vous restez avec nous je donne la
parole à Arnaud est-ce que l'Inter
syndical ça a été préjudiciable à
Philippe Martinez est-ce que le fait
d'avoir été main dans la main avec
Laurent Berger ça lui reproché au sein
de la CGT et au sein de sa base non pas
véritablement parce que Philippe
Martinez a pu comme les autres
organisations syndicales montraient la
force la présence de la CGT dans les
manifestations d'ailleurs si la CGT en
audience a beaucoup baissé elle a gardé
la quasi-totalité de sa capacité
d'organisation c'est la CGT c'est une
grande organisation syndicale ou plein
de sens du terme capacité à détecter des
futurs militants les former à organiser
des manifestations à occuper le
territoire il y a 803 union locale à la
CGT aucune autre organisation syndicale
n'a un tel tissu proche des entreprises
donc la CGT a plutôt bénéficié de cette
de ces manifestations intercer
syndicales
si vous pouvez rester avec nous monsieur
vivier évidemment on a d'autres
questions pour vous tout à l'heure du
coup sur les conséquences ce que dit
Bernard vivier Arnault ce qui est
intéressant dans ce qui se passe à la
CGT ça nous dit quelque chose aussi sur
la société française et sur le rapport
j'allais dire base élite parce que moi
ce qui me frappe c'est qu'en effet que
quelqu'un qu'on finit Martinez qui quand
même n'apparaît pas facilement comme
quelqu'un qui j'allais dire manque de
fermeté par rapport à un certain nombre
de politiques publiques modérés par les
différents gouvernements soit contestés
par sa base on dit long sur la coupure
qui aujourd'hui est en train de
s'installer y compris c'est ceux qui
font preuve de la plus grande fermeté
entre la base et les dirigeants ça dit
quelque chose sur l'état de la société
française aussi cette crise qui est en
train de d'opérer au sein même de la CGT
alors après c'est pas la première crise
que l'inconnu la CGT rappelle que quand
même 47 48 est faux se créer euh à
l'époque je veux dire au moment
de tension sociale particulièrement
aussi compliqué mais là c'est plutôt les
modérés qui en l'occurrence à l'époque
j'ai à dire au Père cette crise là oui
c'est pleinement illustratif
effectivement de l'ensemble des
problématiques aujourd'hui de ce que
veulent dire que ce que veut dire dans
notre société au fond être une
organisation qui porte la voie des
citoyens quel qu'il soit et si je
reprends un certain nombre de mots qui
ont été utilisés pour caractériser la
situation de la CGT à l'instant dans
l'âge de la confusion ou devons-nous
aller effectivement c'est bien ça et on
voit qu'effectivement ce sont des
questions qui concernent également
l'ensemble des organisations politiques
peut-être même
en partie ça peut sans doute ça
s'applique aussi un petit peu à la CFDT
peut-être aussi pas qu'à la CGT et dans
le milieu politique c'est totalement ça
l'attention entre la concertation la
négociation la confront ation elle est
là aussi dans les on va dire les grandes
problématiques que connaissent les
organisations politiques et donc c'est à
l'unisson effectivement complètement en
reflet de ce qui se passe dans
l'ensemble de la société française où
cette tension démocratique c'est
exaspération sur
quelles sont les voies de sortie de on
va dire de toutes les impasses
politiques et sociales dans lesquels
nous sommes devient vraiment une
question qui s'impose à toutes les
organisations
l'interrogation qu'il faudrait peut-être
se poser c'est de savoir si finalement
cette crise est aussi d'une certaine
manière l'expression de la crise qui
enfin des tensions qui existent à gauche
on voit bien que aujourd'hui il y a
plusieurs gauche aussi et est-ce que
finalement ça impacte ou pas sur
j'allais dire ce qui est en train de se
dérouler à la CGT ce qui se passe entre
les insoumis et le Parti communiste
entre autres voilà est-ce que là aussi
je veux dire ça ça révèle d'une certaine
manière c'est ces conflits là
la CGT est née en 1895 pendant toute la
Troisième République la CGT était dans
une phase de construction et puis ça a
été dit en 1947 48 le Parti communiste
en a pris le contrôle donc en 1948 Force
ouvrière est née poursuivre une CGT
indépendante du Parti communiste on a
vécu là un âge un deuxième âge de la
glaciation et puis l'effondrement du
Parti communiste a rendu la CGT d'une
certaine façon libre
elle-même condamnée à choisir librement
son destin elle n'a pas la culture et
depuis la période Bernard Thibault qui
rappelons-le à tenter cette évolution et
bien il n'y a pas eu de débat et la
problématique est beaucoup plus forte à
la CGT que dans les autres organisations
syndicales maintenant le syndicalisme
français dans son ensemble quand on le
compare aux autres syndicats en Europe
et toujours dans une logique de
contestation plus que de négociation à
la CFDT le travail d'une certaine façon
a été fait il a été magnifiquement
lancée par Nicole nOTA Dans les années
1990 mais la culture générale en France
est toujours de dire la grève ça paye
toujours davantage que la négociation
ailleurs en Europe c'est l'inverse
Bernard Vivien un dernier mot avec vous
puisque on va parler de la réforme des
retraites d'Elisabeth borde d'Emmanuel
Macron est-ce que le départ de Philippe
Martinez que son départ est acté est-ce
que son départ peut affaiblir le
mouvement social est peu syndicale non
pas véritablement si on prend les deux
branches de l'alternative c'est
l'universeliti ou Marie elles sont
finalement sur cette ligne très proche
très proche l'une sera peut-être plus
proche de du camarade Poutou l'eau du
camarade Mélenchon l'eau du camarade
Roussel enfin qu'importe la la ligne de
la CGT sur ce dossier des retraites ne
va pas particulièrement être affaibli et
l'avenir de l'intersyndicale ne va pas
dépendre fondamentalement de la
succession de Philippe Martinez
merci beaucoup merci Bernard Vigier
d'avoir été avec nous pour ce débat
depuis Clermont-Ferrand et on suivra
bien sûr tout ça l'Inter syndical
Elisabeth borne qui rencontre les
syndicats mercredi et on va en parler
justement de cette réforme des retraites
tout de suite et de la manière dont le
gère l'exécutif alors quand un hier
Emmanuel Macron était en déplacement
dans les Hautes-Alpes Emmanuel Macron il
voulait parler du plan o sauf que il a
été rattrapé par la réforme des
retraites l'ambiance était un petit peu
particulière pour ce déplacement on peut
le dire puisque il était effectivement
attendu au lac de Serre-Ponçon par 200
manifestants opposés à la réforme des
retraites vous les voyez sur ces images
on voit des drapeaux de la CGT ou encore
de la Confédération de paysanne dans le
cortège il noient le poisson il vient
soi-disant pour parler de l'eau pour
pacifier mais en fait on n'a pas du tout
envie d'être pacifié pour l'instant on
est dans la révolte à expliquer une
manifestante citée par l'AFP de son côté
Emmanuel Macron a estimé que cette
contestation ne l'empêche pas je cite
d'aller à la rencontre des français
cependant on note qu'il s'est contenté
d'une rencontre avec les élus c'est ça
une déambulation autour du lac assez
loin donc des Français et effectivement
qui étaient réunis il s'est contenté de
cette déambulation avec des élus très
peu de prise de risque on le voit avec
se déplacement mais lors d'une
déclaration il a assumé vouloir avancer
on l'écoute
il y a une contestation sociale qui
existe sur une réforme mais ça veut pas
dire que tout doit s'arrêter et c'est
normal on continue à travailler parce
que il se trouve que il y a toujours des
problèmes d'inflation on doit continuer
à réduire le chômage dans notre pays on
doit répondre aux problèmes de
sécheresse on doit préparer la saison à
venir on doit faire face au sujet
alimentaire on a la géopolitique qui
continue donc c'est normal je fais mon
travail voilà il fait son travail sauf
qu'au Parlement on est beaucoup plus
sceptique exemple cette semaine au Sénat
aucune séance publique dans l'hémicycle
à l'exception des habituelles questions
au gouvernement on le sait le projet de
loi immigration qui devait arriver dans
l'hémicycle mardi a été décalé son
examen a été reporté cinédié et aucun
texte majeur n'est prévu à court terme
le Parlement est comme pétrifié écouter
le chef de fil des centriste au Sénat
RMC
je crois que tout le monde attend de
savoir déjà ce que va décider le Conseil
constitutionnel ça donnera de la
visibilité et ensuite j'allais dire on
pourra peut-être regarder quelle sera
l'agenda vers le long terme et après
cela les seuls textes prévus à l'horizon
sont des textes techniques moi le
programmation énergétique là le
programmation militaire les autres
textes sont au point mort Oriane
Emmanuel Macron veut avancer mais est-ce
qu'on est dans un quinquennat à la reine
tout le moment c'est un peu le cas
effectivement on voit que le chef de
l'État hier a voulu nous faire passer le
message absolument inverse qui est dit
non seulement je suis pas à l'arrêt mais
moi je m'occupe des vrais problèmes
sérieux l'eau en particulier dans
l'extrait que vous venez de passer c'est
extrêmement intéressant parce qu'on voit
que le chef de l'État envoie un message
qui est et bien moi pendant ce temps là
je continue à travailler autour des
vrais enjeux il faut faire tourner la
France il faut régler les vrais
problèmes faut s'occuper des vraies
questions il est entouré des lieux
locaux hier extrêmement intéressant la
dimension territoriale et le locaux
étaient omniprésente il était entouré
des Luc locaux qui n'ont cessé de
manifester à son égard de la courtoisie
de la déférence le maire de la petite
commune se disait incroyablement honoré
il avait raison de l'être humain
[Musique]
de la République on lui a manifesté de
la reconnaissance se sont succédé à
l'attribut tout un tas d'acteurs locaux
des problématiques de l'eau qui montrait
des expériences concrètes donc voilà
c'était le message hier pendant que
certains
d'autres idéologies et conteste d'autres
relèvent les manches boss et s'occupent
des vrais problèmes de la France
Emmanuel Macron il y avait clairement
une volonté de tourner la page lors de
ses déplacements Arnaud en fait il y a
deux lectures qu'on peut faire du moment
qu'on traverse première lecture c'est la
lecture qui serait favorable au
gouvernement on a connu un tassement des
mobilisations mardi c'était mardi oui je
sais plus où c'était oui c'est mardi
dernier mardi on sait plus parce qu'il y
en a beaucoup donc après on finit par
confondre mardi
et une fine et cette essoufflement va
profiter à l'exécutif d'autant plus que
les vacances arrivent donc ça va être
plus difficile ça c'est la version
j'allais dire positive pour le
gouvernement l'autre version qui est un
peu plus j'allais dire
j'allais dire un peu pessimiste c'est de
considérer que un pour l'instant les
mobilisations malgré tout reste soutenu
et que quand le veuille non même la
mobilisation mardi qui était plus
difficile était quand même importantes
après j'allais dire 9 journées d'action
quand même depuis le 19 janvier donc de
ce point de vue là c'est à de crédits
des syndicats dans leur capacités
opérationnelles à continuer à mobiliser
deuxième élément l'unité syndicale pour
l'instant demeure malgré tout troisième
élément et c'est à mon avis l'élément
peut-être le plus important c'est que le
soutien de l'opinion publique reste
encore très massif et même l'opinion
publique considère pour une grande
majorité qu'il faut continuer le
mouvement qui a été initié depuis le 19
janvier et quatrième élément c'est ce
que vous avez
aborder dans le dans le reportage c'est
que le problème c'est qu'on a une sorte
de grippage institutionnelle puisque on
voit qu'aujourd'hui globalement le
Parlement d'une certaine façon est à
l'arrêt donc ça c'est quand même une
vraie difficulté pour Emmanuel Macron le
problème encore une fois je pense pour
Emmanuel Macron et pour l'exécutif
depuis le printemps depuis les élections
législatives c'est qu'encore une fois on
se retrouve avec un exécutif sous la
5ème République qui a la plus faible
majorité relative qu'un exécutif est
connu depuis le début de la cinquième
République et ça c'est quand même un
vice qui est un vice considérable pour
avancer dans une situation sociale qui
est compliquée dans une relation avec
l'opinion qui est compliquée avec un
délai de traitement par le Conseil
constitutionnel qui est très long dans
le temps médiatique et sachant qu'il y a
des mobilisations qui continuent dans la
rue de voir attendre un mois et avoir
pendant ce 1 mois une situation qui
s'enlise ou qui qui se pétrifient ou qui
voilà qui peut aussi être du
pourrissement est-ce qu'on voit que
c'est aussi comme ça que c'est perçu par
les opposants au gouvernement et voilà
ce délai il semble interminable le 14
avril et cette échéances pour la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
il y a un vrai effectivement un vrai
enjeu à la fois pour les organisations
syndicales de continuer à maintenir la
pression pendant ce pendant ce pendant
ce temps je n'imagine pas que l'opinion
publique va être très sensible au fond à
ce délai l'ancrage de l'opinion dans une
opposition très forte qui traverse
toutes les couches de la société et même
tous les électorats il y a même des
électeurs d'Emmanuel Macron qui
s'opposent à cette réforme c'est
tellement profond qu'on n'imagine pas
une inversion de tendance liée à au fond
un vais soufflement dans l'opinion ça
non les de ce point du là je pense que
les dés ont été jetés il y a déjà un bon
moment en ce qui concerne les logiques
de de l'opinion en revanche c'est vrai
que
la décision qui va être prise par le
Conseil constitutionnel il y a pas que
la le projet du gouvernement et aussi le
rip et donc l'initiative partagée c'est
vrai que les deux créent une sorte
d'attente extrêmement forte tant qu'on a
pas cette décision c'est un peu du
surplace effectivement j'imagine que du
côté de l'exécutif et peut-être du côté
des syndicats dans les coulisses on
profite quand même de ce moment pour
maintenir le dialogue et pour essayer de
tester la zone de confort ou d'inconfort
de chacun jusqu'où chacun est prêt à
pousser un petit peu cette idée d'une
d'une reprise du dialogue et un dernier
mot sur Elisabeth borne puisqu'elle a
été chargée d'élargir la majorité par le
chef de l'État sauf que les dans les
couloirs du Sénat les les sénateurs nous
disent
comment est-ce que un sénateur LR ou
centriste ou qui pourrait être ma
concompatible pour y accepter cette main
tendue sachant que dans une échéance à
moyen terme à court terme et ils avaient
de bande peut éventuellement sauter
c'est-à-dire elle peut être remplacée
par un autre Premier ministre etc
comment est-ce que dans ce contexte et
bien elle pourrait avoir des ralliements
alors qu'elle est si faible
politiquement et si affaiblit par la
séquence aussi peut-être un peu ça le
message d'hier de la part d'Emmanuel
Macron à Elisabeth borne la réforme des
retraites et moi je m'occupe du reste
des autres sujets je continue à avancer
sur les réformes du quinquennat il
fallait que de toute façon que le
Président de la République sorte après
une séquence qui quand même ces derniers
jours avaient été particulièrement
compliqué je me rappelle j'étais là on
était là tous les deux avec Bruno
contreses la semaine dernière au moment
où on annonçait la visite de Charles III
et on a appris deux heures plus tard
le 3 ne venez pas oui ça semble tout à
fait une éternité et en plus après vous
aviez l'annonce de de la participation
du président de la République au Stade
de France pour un match de football
n'oubliez pas il ne s'est pas rendu donc
il fallait quand même qu'il montre qu'il
est capable de sortir de l'Elysée et
d'aller à la rencontre du terrain donc
il y avait aussi ce message montrer que
ce président n'est pas empêché quelque
soit je veux dire la nature de la de la
de la guérison de la contestation
sociale donc il y avait aussi ceux-là
dans cette visite sur le terrain avec
comme la parfaitement dit Bruno des élus
autour de lui donc montrer que
finalement bon c'est compliqué mais ça
reste sous ça reste sous contrôle
ensuite en effet il y a la relation au
Premier ministre mais moi je pense que
la question du Premier ministre je
dirais elle est presque secondaire dans
cette affaire on peut considérer en
effet qu'un changement de Premier
ministre est une arme politique ça ça
l'a toujours été sur la 5e République
François Mitterrand le faisait
parfaitement sauf que François Pitt
Mitterrand faisait en sorte de ne pas se
retrouver en première ligne lorsqu'il y
avait une crise majeure et une crise
sociale et il était capable de bouger je
rappelle quand même que en 83 au moment
des grandes manifestations de la défense
pour l'école privée un moment donné il a
pris la décision qui ne devait pas le
jadis entre le gêner idéologiquement qui
plus est d'ailleurs de retirer de
retirer de retirer ce texte un dernier
mot pour sur cette affaiblissement
d'Elisabeth borne Elizabeth borne la
semaine prochaine elle doit recevoir les
parties politiques y compris de
l'opposition évidemment les communistes
et les insoumis ont refusé d'y aller eux
ils veulent rencontrer Emmanuel Macron
ils appellent à marcher vers l'Élysée
c'est symptomatique ça de ce que
représente les abattement
en tout cas c'est vrai que c'est
évocateur de cet affaiblissement de
Matignon ça c'est certain
Elisabeth borne a une difficulté dans
l'opinion toutes les enquêtes de pignon
qui ont été réalisés sur l'image
d'Elisabeth borne au delà de la
popularité qui est faible comme le
président et la moins de 30% aujourd'hui
de popularité mais du point de vue de
l'image il y a quelque chose de
totalement différent par rapport à
Emmanuel Macron autant Emmanuel Macron
continue à susciter beaucoup de
polarisation beaucoup d'affects beaucoup
même de sentiments très positifs très
négatif Elizabeth pin depuis le début a
beaucoup de mal à installer un
personnage de Elizabeth World première
ministre les Français qu'il aime
beaucoup disent elbeuce elle est
sérieuse c'est quelqu'un qui est qui
maîtrise les dossiers par contre c'est
vrai que ça ne crée pas autour d'elle
une image qui est une image auquel les
Français ont pu s'identifier s'attacher
fortement et en face et bien il y a
l'image au contraire d'une technocrate
un peu inhumaine qui prends des
décisions sans vraiment s'occuper des
conséquences ou alors quelqu'un qui n'a
pas d'autonomie par rapport au chef de
par rapport chef de l'État donc elle
n'est pas arrivée à installer dans
l'opinion un personnage comme Édouard
Philippe ou j'encaissait avec son pull
faire et on verra bien sûr ce qui se
passe la semaine prochaine en
rencontrant avec les partis politiques
rencontres avec les syndicats également
c'est vendredi c'est l'heure de notre
page patrimoine vous le savez Fabien
Ricard nous emmène à la découverte d'un
petit joyau d'architecture médiévale
longtemps oublié au coeur de la follée
et de la forêt de Rambouillet dans les
Yvelines le prieuré des Moulinaux datant
du 12e siècle il menaçait de s'écrouler
avec l'aide des collectivités et le
soutien des habitants les travaux de
restauration enfin démarrer
l'amortissement d'un combat de 10 ans
pour le maire de la commune
c'est un petit morceau de forêt que
Thierry conver et fier de nous faire
visiter on arrive sur le sur le site de
du de la chapelle ce qui reste de du
prieuré des Moulineaux de ce prieuré du
12e siècle ne tient plus debout que
cette ancienne chapelle sa rénovation a
débuté il y a quelques semaines c'est
une grosse émotion parce qu'on attend ça
depuis des années des années
il aura fallu 10 ans à Monsieur le Maire
pour réunir les fonds nécessaires avant
de démarrer les travaux là on a une vue
là sur le sur l'intérieur de la de la
chapelle il y avait de la végétation qui
commence à rentrer première étape
libérez les murs de la végétation qui
les avait engloutis sans affaiblir la
structure
c'est un arrachement le départ avant
apparemment de du couvent en fait il y
avait le c'était le dortoir qui était là
le dortoir des prieurs le clou du
spectacle c'est la voûte de la chapelle
ouverte aux intempéries ces jours
étaient comptés menaçant tout le
bâtiment c'est la voûte mais la partie
supérieure de la voûte qui était sous la
toiture en fait sous la couverture la
charpente qui a été démontée le travail
réalisé par les maçons du 12e siècle
force l'admiration du chef de chantier
Olivier thérieux ce qu'ils ont fait ça
va bouger c'est à 800 ans c'est dans le
même état la voûte quasiment quasiment
c'est incroyable on a pas grand chose à
faire dessus à peine la restauration
si tu es sur un terrain privé la
chapelle était délaissée par son
propriétaire en 2014 la mairie a obtenu
que le site soit classé avant d'acquérir
le terrain deux ans plus tard il a fallu
ensuite chercher des financements 400000
euros réunis auprès des collectivités et
de donateurs privés un parcours du
combattant il faut la volonté de la
municipalité et c'est cette volonté
parce que naturellement l'argent qu'on
va mettre dans le patrimoine c'est de
l'argent qu'on mettra pas dans les
lampadaires et les trottoirs
et donc il faut déjà faire comprendre
à nos administrés que le patrimoine ça
fait partie
ça fait partie de toutes les dépenses
d'investissement qu'une commune doit
assumer
sans végétation dis donc
pour associer les habitants de la
commune la mairie s'est appuyée sur une
association sauvons les Moulineaux sa
vice-présidente Hélène charrier est une
passionnée du patrimoine ce site il a
une particularité c'est qu'il n'a pas
été abîmé par le temps il y a eu peu
d'activité humaine et surtout pas
d'activité humaine contemporaine donc il
y en a pas de conduite d'eau on n'a pas
d'électricité le site il est dans son
jus que les gens viennent ici le enfin
tombe amoureux de ce site il y a un
charme ici qui se joue qui qui est
incomparable parce que l'environnement
est préservé depuis toujours
à 100 km de là près de Rouen on
travaille aussi sur le chantier de
Poigny dans cette entreprise ont été
rapatriés les éléments de la charpente
du prieuré
donc on peut voir le plan ici en 3D en
fait avec différentes couleurs donc tout
ce qui est en rouge et tout ce qui va
être remplacé les éléments anciens sont
assemblés avec de nouvelles pièces
taillées sur mesure l'entreprise qui
fabrique aussi une partie de la future
charpente de Notre-Dame à le
savoir-faire
ces missions en ligne donc sur une épure
donc les pures c'est le dessin de la
charpente à l'échelle 1 on met
directement la pièce à sa place en fait
au dessus des lignes quoi à la plomb ça
nous permet d'empiler les choses et de
pouvoir
les tracer quoi une fois reconstituer la
charpente sera réassembler sur le site
et offrira de nouveau une protection à
la chapelle du prieuré des Moulineaux
pour le maire le chemin ne s'arrête pas
là il poursuit sa recherche de
financement pour restaurer d'anciens
bassins attenant à la chapelle ainsi que
les murs d'enceintes
voilà pour ce reportage la semaine
prochaine on vous emmène dans une usine
de chocolat puisque ça sera la veille du
week-end de Pâques Quentin en attendant
on va regarder ce qu'elle a une de nos
journées régionaux
[Musique]
évidemment la presse régionale revient
sur la visite du chef de l'étaillère
dans les hautes quotidienne régionale à
largement commenté cette visite parfois
avec malice Macron retour sur Terre
écrit en une le Dauphiné Libéré le
journal de Grenoble il a changé d'air
virgule parler dos lit-on dans les pages
intérieures du titre La Dépêche du Midi
à Toulouse qui écrit plan o macro macros
sort les rames elle a crise sociale et
politique et dans tous les esprits mais
elle Macron qui part à la reconquête de
l'opinion après plus de deux mois loin
du terrain espère tourner la page des
retraites écrit le journal et enfin la
Provence à Marseille qui parle d'un
Macron à la relance on continue de
travailler a-t-il martelé inflexible sur
le départ à 64 ans écrit le journal
alors la presse régionale qui revient
aussi sur l'objectif initial ce
déplacement
eau on ferme le robinet titre Le Midi
Libre à Montpellier qui revient sur les
53 mesures annoncées hier par Emmanuel
Macron le progrès un lion ainsi sur cet
objectif fixé par le chef de l'État 10%
d'économie d'eau dans tous les secteurs
d'ici 2030 et enfin terminé avec le
Républicain Lorrain c'est à Metz qui
parle d'éviter le scénario catastrophe
avec à l'intérieur aussi un des pages
sur l'agriculture qui est au pied du mur
elle doit modifier ses pratiques
explique un responsable de l'Agence de
l'Eau rein Meuse on voit que chaque
région en fait et bien s'approprie le
débat sur l'eau autre grand titre ce
matin cette actualité autour de la
défense des dauphins voilà dauphin
menacé la vie des experts titre ce matin
le Télégramme alors en fait c'est un
sujet qui est loin d'être anecdotique
pourquoi parce que nous sommes au
lendemain d'une journée morte dans les
ports de France comme on en a rarement
vu ces dernières années en France à
Brest plusieurs centaines de pêcheurs se
sont rassemblés sur le port tirant des
fusées de détresse et faisant brûler des
fumigènes depuis leur chalutier au Havre
également une soixantaine de bateaux
bloqué le port des mobilisations très
fortes des pêcheurs contre les
interdictions européennes de péchés qui
vont être mises en place mais aussi
également contre la décision du Conseil
d'État de fermer certaines zones de
pêche dans l'Atlantique pour préserver
les dauphins on y revient d'où ce débat
sur la défense des mammifères marins en
face la colère des marins-pêcheurs est
forte on est devenu des parias on est
devenu une profession à abattre
l'identité l'un d'entre eux à l'Orient
dans le Nord c'est la fermeture de
l'usine butoni qui provoque le désarroi
on perd plus qu'un emploi ce sont les
mots que l'on peut lire à la Une de La
Voix du Nord ce matin avec ce visage se
désarroi d'une salarié hier lors de
l'annonce effectivement de la fermeture
de l'usine de Caudry cette usine qui
était dans la tourmente depuis un an
rapidement si j'ai plus léger quoi oui
on va finir sur un sourire alors on voit
pas le sourire des gagnants mais en tout
cas il se cachent derrière cette
pancarte et ce record ce jackpot
historique dans la Sarthe 102 millions
d'euros qui ont été donc gagnés par ces
deux Sarto à bravo à eux ils ont de la
chance merci Quentin
in
[Musique]